where r sub R a game dev for web
designers hmm so we're dead for you may
call me better or better as they call me
in Brazil or with her if you're an
English speaker whatever man my name is
weird and hard so you may call me
anywhere anything you want I think it's
good to understand where I'm coming from
I worked as a web designer for six years
and then I got into the gaming industry
and worked there for another six years
so that's where my experience comes I
also teach classes at a university in
Brazil I also teach all your classes and
web technology classes so when I hope
that I can get my experience to join
these both worlds here today and I'm
also a music composer so I do a lot of
stuff these days after I've been working
for four years in a company called nano
studio which was a small but like 15
people can company in Rio I became an
indie game developer so this is me in my
partner eager and we are mini pixel we
are small indie game developer and we
are we've been working in this game
called warlocks tower warlock star it's
a puzzle game it's been awarded in two
categories in Brazil so we've been very
glad about that and we've been dedicated
full time to warlocks tower but where
else i will come later now i want to
speak a little disclaimer here i will be
talking about to the games okay because
if you really want to become a
professional game developer working on
tripod games like GTA or Skyrim and
these kinds of games well the web isn't
ready yet WebGL is great it's cool but
you can make Skyrim to run on a browser
yet we'll eventually get there so if you
want to do this now do yourself a favor
and
go learn C++ or C sharp and play with
unity and all these kind of kinds of
engines but I had my background as i
told you is as a web designer so I'm
taking a different route here so don't
four games I'm so glad that I'm speaking
after Rachel because she have shown you
how amazing the dome can be so it's
pretty it's a little bit easier for me
to get my point across so you may ask me
really come on WebGL is far better
canvas is far better why on earth would
you use the dome for games well first of
all this is not a new idea back in 2005
when people called website animations d
HTML who was there back man only a few
of you yeah this guy was already making
cool games at the time when browser
browsers weren't that fast so in 2009
another guy called Trevor collie he made
an engine called GMP which is largely
based off jQuery it has a similar API
and all the objects that you're seeing
here our dome objects are Dom node so
plenty of dips in short and then in 2010
these other guys selling our server I
hope I'm getting his name right he came
with game query who gets the gas we
changing it's based off right so but all
these engines these pioneering engines
of which i'm sure most of you haven't
heard about have one problem back then
the work kind of slow because all we
have to make animations back then were a
set time out and set interval and today
we know that these methods aren't they
were never fast and they are not fast
today even though they're faster but
they can't cut it and the standard
against which we compared everything
back then was our good old friend flesh
so everyone who was playing on the web
or making
further for the web were making on flash
because flesh may be a lot of things but
it wasn't slow back then it was a pretty
fast engine for for the browser it was
the best thing we had so in 2010 you all
know what happened right Steve Jobs
killed flash all together which is a
good thing for us right oui oui people
that like web standards so from then on
HTML game engines flourished there is a
lot of HTML game engines these days you
may have heard of some of them but most
of them are canvas engines people don't
don't care about the dawn they are
canvas they are WebGL most of them don't
don't contemplate the dumb as a
rendering target most but these these
for example they do present an
alternative so you can switch a
rendering target and render to done so
you may think that you're getting what
I'm talking right Oh game dev by web
designer so you'll just develop your
game on a traditional gaming engine and
then switch the target and that's it
that's dumb game development well not
exactly my idea is a little different
because there's a small problem game dev
is totally unlike front end dev it's a
totally different way of thinking and
I'm not a professional developer by all
means I've been noise a designer or an
artist or a musician so for me to think
in terms of game development was always
pretty hard and why is that let's take a
look at our classic fronting approach
that we all love which is with throw
content at our HTML and we see this
content we visually format it via CSS
these days we have auto refresh but back
then we will go at five ffff over some
of you are who I bet are still doing
this so the thing is while we are f5 in
our browsers we're
what we're working on we don't have to
abstract it in our minds and then after
everything is laid out we'll make it
come alive with JavaScript so how many
of you use this workflow here nope okay
some of you this is called in computer
graphics we call this the retain mode
the retain mode is when you don't have
to worry about the drawing loop the
things they are being draw draw on
screen so the classic game game dev
approach on the other side is a little
different you have a game loop that
takes like a clock and at each tick of
this clock you make lots of
verifications like victory conditions
States collisions or except at each tick
of the clock you're verifying this but
because there's no other way to develop
games and verify if your if your player
is colliding verify player input so if
you're making games that are heavily
reliant on player reflexes that's the
way we should develop games this is
called immediate mode when you have
control over your drawing loop you have
control over each and every frame that
goes into the screen this is your right
approach the right way however and
however no no not however it is faster
it is more efficient and it's more
flexible so you have full control over
your game so it is the right way if any
of you want to be a professional game
developer this is the way you should go
this is the way you should learn this is
the way games are made to be honest
however if you're like me you will find
it that it's also more complex more
abstract as I told you before you have
to think beforehand before you get to
see things happening on screen you have
to program a lot it's less friendly for
visual thinkers because of this very
reason I find it to be so and it's a
completely different way of coding so
if you use to coding websites and you ok
now I'm going to run phaser it's a
completely way of cording you have to
relearn everything you know and in my
life I have procrastinated a lot of
times I started learning a game engine
and I haven't gone to the end because I
found two different I I didn't have time
back then so in 2014 I read this book
jquery the game developed many
essentials and this book is all about
making games with the dawn after that I
made these games which happened to be
client works these are simple games but
they were made with DOM and I was
amazing bleh I was like man I can make
games I can finally make games and
what's best i can make games exactly
like i make websites so what i really
mean by game dev for web designers is
not take a traditional engine switch
you're arranging target and you're set
no I want you to I want you to see the
beauty of developing games by using HTML
CSS and JavaScript and to convince you I
made a proof of concept here which is
our game warlocks tower I made a
simplified version of warlocks hour
which is running on the dawn and i will
show you right now let me put this here
so i can use my mouth okay so this is
warlocks tower as you can see the
inspector is open so if i put my mouse
here well walls are let me explain to
you play as mailman team which is this
guy here and he must take as i told you
this is a version of a larger game which
was developing lure in this game you
play as mailman team and you have to
take a ladder to the evil warlock who
lives on the top of the tower however
the tower is cursed so at each step you
take you lose one life okay so if I
screw up I die these controls are for
mobile use so if you wish to access the
URL later you can try it it's mostly
working on Chrome mobile chrome and I
think I follow as well but it's a little
worried and I would explain why but
let's stick to it if you can see where
if I expect here Tim himself is a div so
he's here okay and there is JavaScript
animation going on well he walks and oh
I forgot to tell you there are three
live gems in five live gems so the
puzzle is that I must get to the exit
that I conveniently painted blue for you
and by taking the gems so if we had time
I would ask one of you to come here and
play because I love to see people
playing it were lost our however I'll
just play for you so you saw me dying
already well die again and the idea in
this level is that I have to pick I
don't need this gem I'd have to pick
this one this one and then go straight
to the exit okay my main idea here
besides proving to you that I can take
our commercial product which is a
award-winning product that will take to
the market in two or three months and
make with HTML and CSS I also wanted to
make a proof of concept of something I
find very interesting which is using
HTML as a level design too ok if you use
a live server as I'm doing here a node
live server and I most of you how many
of you are using life service these days
most of you the ones who aren't should
because it makes her life really easier
so if you're using a live server
i coded it so as to make the level
design process as streamlined as I could
so all we have to do I'm using tables
here not because I think that you see
the tables for your website because it's
a grid-based game so i found it i found
the tables to be more intuitive as a
level design tool in this case instead
of using just dips with classes or
section and a div inside a section or an
article i just use a table here so if i
want to create a new event here i will
create for example a number three Jen
here in the last column okay then I'll
just put the question 3 and when it
refreshes here's my jam so I can make my
level in real time by using good and old
HTML I can make it pretty fast I'm used
to making levels using a level editor
called tiled and I wanted to reproduce
this workflow as good as I could with
HTML I took this idea from the the
system i usually used to author my
slides when i teach classes which is
revealed Jas and after some years of
using reveal Jas I was amazed of how
fast I could work authoring with HTML
and I bet you also can author pretty
fast with HML so of course I won't be
making a fool ever here because you have
to think for that but you can see that I
have the main events here that allow me
to make a warlock star level which are
the three jam the five gem and the whole
with that you can make a lot of levels I
also implemented a quick level oder so i
can switch levels here and load on
another level so i could for instance
die and well here's the first level
again as i told you this is a prototype
it's a prototype i made just for this
talk then of course there are some
quirks here and there but it's totally
playable and it's so the levels are
totally do
there's a levels folder and if you
create a new HTML for it will appear
here on the list for you to load and
you've gotten yourself a new level so if
you want to experiment with it I will
make it available through github and
cold pan later and you can design your
own warlocks tower levels so my main
takeaways here one of one of which i
have talked a lot about is that HTML is
a great level design to not only because
we're used to it but because our IDEs
autocomplete a lot of stuff so we can
work really fast with it and if you want
prefer to use a preprocessor like a
hammer or such an elegant language you
probably work even faster I've used a
lot of CSS pseudo elements so to create
the gems to create the holes the events
and to make the the lab the level design
process as straightforward as I could so
my main objective was I just add classes
and stuff will happen so I use a lot of
pseudo elements for that of course I use
CSS animations for the gems and a cool
thing about using CSS animations for
that is that you can specify different
animation timings which in normal game
engines it's kind of a pain to make
stuff happen at different rates so by
using CSS for our animations for the
static objects like the gems the gym
doesn't have to move around they are
there and they are just a sprite sprite
sheet being played through CSS with the
steps function so it's pretty CSS is an
amazing tool and CSS is also great if
you're like we are a developer working
on the game logic and you have a
designer or artists working on the
visual side you can parallel eyes the
work pretty pretty easily with CSS your
designer may make just like we do on
websites right that your designer may
make
new level themes new spreadsheets new
monsters and may test all of it just by
using CSS he doesn't have to get his
hands dirty with JavaScript if he
doesn't why doesn't want it jquery is
too very handy for this kind of stuff
because when you're working with with an
engine where everything our downloads
there are jquery is a very good tool to
query the dome as you may know and it
returns you the jquery object with which
already comes with a lot of information
that you can use for for your game so it
is still a handy tool for this uses but
you can still go vanilla JavaScript no
problem with that and and do the same
another thing I use I use a lot is image
rendering pixelated which is a fairly
recent CSS rule and it's not supported
in all major browsers yet for instance i
founded that on mobile iOS the game is
too blurry because the idea will be
image rendering pixelated because this
kind of image rendering mode uses the
nearest neighbourhood algorithm which is
the algorithm you need to scale your
pixel art and pixel art is it is always
a good fit for the web because it's
small i'm using 16 by 16 sprites so it's
ultra fast my CSS files my javascript
files are probably larger than my images
and and they scale well it so if you're
using a preprocessor like less or says
you can just create a variable with a
scale factor and then just scale the
screen and because of the nearest
neighbor already algorithm if you scale
the screen it will adjust pretty well so
you can write some media queries and
scale the screen according to your
resolutions so these are the takeaways
and I wanted to talk about what's
different now because I told you that
back then those pioneering
engines were slow right so these days as
we know browser Jas engines are way
faster because the vendors are trying to
provide a native life experience these
days we also have a request animation
frame we don't have to rely we also have
of course at all the school high-tech
stuff that rachel has shown you so you
won't need even to rely on request
animation frame in the future then of
course we have optimized libraries like
gzip and velocity that take care of all
the optimization you need with repaints
and reflows that is the major
performance bottleneck when you're
trying to manipulate the Dom and move
things to the dome however since I'm
using CSS animations as well the most of
the animations the static animations get
uploaded to the GPU anyway so using gzip
in combination is a good choice until we
start using the web animations API and
one thing that we never had and as a
musician I was always really sad about
that it's cross-browser audio support so
now we have that through the audio
element which is a little quirky and of
course through the Web Audio API the Web
Audio API is amazing it provides a lot
of possibilities for games like spatial
audio and dynamic audio and we are
really close to having it supported
widespread so another thing if I have
time do I have time ok I wanted to talk
about is the types of games that we can
make is that of course we can make we
cannot make every type of game by using
the dawn but we can make fairly a fairly
good quantity of genres such as of
course rapid prototyping genre is not a
joiner I start with it with it because i
find that HTML and CSS and javascript
are really good for rapid prototyping
you can just throw your code there and
test game ideas because in traditional
game design
we usually test our ideas with pen and
paper will test our ideas with board
games if you study in a game design
class and you problem your teacher will
probably take you one step back and tell
you to design board games to test your
rule set so we can take one step further
from that then test our rule set by
using an HTML Javascript and CSS you can
make digital card games you can make
digital board games you could make
management simulators and this one which
is game dev tycoon and was made by using
web technologies and it's a great game
it's an awesome game if I haven't played
you should strategy RPGs like
TextExpander Fantasy Tactics vandal
hearts Fire Emblem this kind of kinds of
games are easy to easy easily doable
they are pretty similar to what I've
shown you in war all-star of course a
point-and-click adventure games are
totally but doable with Dom puzzles of
course as I have proven you and most
turn based games can be achieved by
using John technologies okay if you rely
on the player taking actions
turn-by-turn if you don't rely on a game
clock on very fun events at each tick of
a clock you can make it by using the Dom
you just react to play events and you
react to the terms there are some jurors
however that you shouldn't even try
because these are the games based off
reflexes that i told you about where you
have to make lots of verifications and
you couldn't you it would be quickly
drain by callback hell by using the DOM
and you probably wouldn't have a
performance anyway so action platformers
first-person shooters shoot em ups
fighting games anything with frantic
gameplay lots of sprites collisions
real-time events for that stick to
traditional engines you don't have to
get out of the web you may use for
instance craft tjs which is a pretty
easy engine to use you may use phaser
you may also use construct
which is a technology in which you make
games by pointing and clicking so if you
don't want to call whatsoever if you're
getting home tired from a day of code in
JavaScript and you just want to play
constructed nice tool and it's all it
renders to WebGL so it's also web based
rendering wise and the last thing I want
I want to say is of course i know i'm
talking about the heck here and i hope
you also know i'm talking about a hack
the dome were was made for you I for
using interfaces for content heavy stuff
it wasn't made for her game so I'm aware
that I'm advocating here for a heck but
it's a good heck it's a hack that will I
hope hopefully will will encourage you
who already have this skill set who
already know how to code website to code
games i wish i can open your mind to how
many games you could be doing so don't
procrastinate don't wait for the day
when you finally learn phaser or unity
or unreal engine just start making your
games with what you know i think that's
it you can reach me at better at midi
pixel com I'm w mythical pixel at
Twitter and you should definitely check
out the original warlocks are we have a
built for pc mac and linux and we have
already in this build and this demo
build which is free of course we have
30-something levels and i hope you can
play it and enjoy it and hopefully
provide me with feedback so i can make
the game better so gracias
[Applause]